13 monate dauerte der mammutprozess vor
dem freiburger landgericht
elf männer waren angeklagt im oktober
2018 eine damals 18 jährige studentin in
einem gebüsch vor einer diskothek
nacheinander brutal vergewaltigt zu
haben
heute wurden sie wegen unterlassener
hilfeleistung und vergewaltigung zu
haftstrafen zwischen vier monaten und
fünfeinhalb jahren verurteilt das urteil
nahmen sie dabei relativ gelangweilt
entgegen bis zum schluss zeigten sie
keine reue
und anstatt sich für ihre scheußliche
tat in grund und boden zu schämen
verhöhnten sie ihr opfer vor gericht
über ihre anwälte ließen wir ausrichten
der geschlechtsverkehr sei nicht nur
einvernehmlich gewesen sondern von den
mädchen massiv eingefordert worden
das ist natürlich eine absolut
ungeheuerliche behauptung die
fassungslos macht man kann sich kaum
vorstellen dass eine junge frau die
vorher unter drogen gesetzt wurde sich
sex mit acht fremden männern wünscht
noch dazu in dieser umgebung im dreck
liegen in einem gebüsch das sah auch der
richter so ernannte ist eine standard
einlassung die nicht besonders originell
ist allein dass man 43 verhandlungstage
gebraucht hat zeigt dass die
beweisaufnahme sehr umfangreich war es
wurden zeugen gehört die oft
multiplikatoren der angeklagten waren
und entsprechende geschichten vom
hörensagen oder ja selbst als
schlussfolgerung ausgedachte geschichten
erzählt haben
der wesentliche teil der beweisaufnahme
kamen dann eigentlich gegen ende des
prozesses als die verschiedenen
gutachten über die objektiven befunden
dass dna-spuren insbesondere kamen und
diese dna-spuren treffer die vom
landeskriminalamt so nach und nach
während der ermittlungen geliefert
wurden die waren natürlich der
anhaltspunkt für die anklageerhebung